we won't always see eye to eye oh and
CNN thank you so much for the
wall-to-wall Ebola coverage but two
whole weeks we were one step away from
the walking dead it's that time of year
again where politicians and the press
gather to get roasted by comedians who
make fun of them for things that are
actually huge national concerns the most
wonderful time of the year
I'm Gabe Howe writer and you're just
super cut of the funniest moments from
the White House Illuminati
Correspondents Dinner roll the clips
welcome to the White House
Correspondents Dinner the night when
Washington celebrates itself being
president is never easy I still have to
fix a broken immigration system issue
veto threats all while finding time to
pray five times a day after the midterm
elections my advisors asked me mr.
president do you have a bucket list I
have something that rhymes with bucket
list take executive action on
immigration bucket Rick Santorum
announced that he would not attend the
same-sex wedding of a friend or a loved
one to which gays and lesbians across
the country responded that's not going
to be a problem on Saturday Night Live
Cicely impersonates CNN anchor Baldwin's
usually the only people impersonating
journalists on CNN are journalists on
CNN and Bernie Sanders might run
apparently some folks really want to see
a pot-smoking socialist in the White
House we could get a third Obama term
after all since I'm only a comedian I'm
not gonna try to tell you politicians
how to do politics or whatever that's
not my job that'd be like you guys
telling me what to do with my body
I mean you in a mansion it is great to
be here at the Washington Hilton is
something a prostitute might say to a
congressman
let's give it up for the Secret Service
don't be too hard on those guys you know
cuz they're the only law enforcement
agency in the country that will get in
trouble if a black man gets shot I
invited Luther my anger translator to
join me here tonight despite our
differences we count on the press to
shed light on the most important issues
of the day
Hillary will have to rage use sums of
money to climate change is bone-dry it
looked like a trailer for the new Mad
Max movie up in there
y'all take the Bradley Cooper he came
here because he wants to talk to Chuck
Todd he needed a glass of water nine out
of the ten hottest years ever came in
the last decade instead of doing
anything about it we got elected
officials throwing snowballs in the
Senate okay I think it is crazy what
about our kids
what kind of stupid short-sighted
irresponsible that was funny wasn't that
funny please laughs he's got a drone on
me okay now is the time when you can
subscribe more updates on important
things like what our country is doing
video games
I'm Gabe horror writer and I'll see you
guys next year when the flowers are in
bloom and the birds come out and once
again it's okay to make fun of the
people who control all of our lives
bye